if you're not sure what businesses start
you've got to start actually trying some
things out and see what sticks you're
not gonna come to the perfect answer
only by thinking about it you've got to
actually start doing things hi I'm Evan
Carmichael your friend in all things
entrepreneurship and today Manson a
question from one of my readers Lathan
who wrote in saying he's a young
entrepreneur he wants to start a
business doesn't know what to do except
that he wants to be in business for
himself and he's wondering should he
just jump at the next opportunity that
comes to him or should he sit back and
wait for the perfect opportunity that's
a great question Lathan congratulations
on making the decision to be an
entrepreneur it can be a tough one a
member was hard for me when I was
getting my first business going to
answer your question you've got to go
and actually start trying different
things so remember when I sold my first
business and I was looking at what do I
do next there was this big hole in my
heart and I didn't know what I wanted to
do I felt like I just given up my baby
with the business and I didn't have to
go and work but I felt like I wanted to
do something and I got to the point
where I was writing in a journal things
that I enjoy doing and didn't enjoy
doing hoping that that would lead me
somewhere you know if I did enough of
the things that I enjoy doing an ongoing
basis I could turn that into a business
and I hooked up with a venture capital
company because I was curious about
learning the venture capital side of
things and helped them bring in new
clients to raise money for new customers
who are trying to grow their business
and that was a lot of fun there was a
lot of learning there I hooked up with a
startup software company at the same
time and started this new business
getting it off the ground
neither of those ended up being what I
ended up doing longer-term which was
started nephron Carmical comm turning it
into a business but they both helped get
me there I didn't commit to doing either
of them full time I was dipping my toes
in offering some expertise learning
along the way and seeing if it was a
right fit for me or not and the only way
for me to figure that out was to get in
and start trying to do it keeping a
journal help so I could figure out what
I enjoy doing and what I didn't enjoy
doing one of the lightbulb turning
points for me was when I started doing
presentations about entrepreneurship and
I realized I wanted to do more of these
I loved doing them so much I loved
helping entrepreneurs and I had to keep
finding a way to do it to do it and
you'll get to that moment and it's a
process of self-discovery that you have
to go to you're on your journey but you
don't start a journey just sitting at
home you know you've got to go out there
and start trying different things that
sound appealing but not with a huge
expectation that this is gonna turn into
your your million dollar idea if you put
massive expectations on things then
you're setting yourself up for failure
go out experience it see if you like
doing it so if you want to do it again
and again and again see if this is what
you were born to do or not you've got to
find that and you will if you look at
Steve Jobs founder of Apple he was in
college universe and he dropped out he
dropped out of his classes because he
wasn't enjoying it and he started
dropping in on classes that talked about
typography and fonts and he had no idea
what that would mean for him he just
found that interesting and he dropped in
on computer building clubs
and again he had no idea what it was
gonna mean he was just following
something that was curious to him and
led to the creation of Apple and this
huge company and massive wealth for him
but at the time was scary you know and
his friends and family saying you're
dropping out of university you're
dropping out of college and you're
you're going to sit in on other classes
for free and you're going to hang out
with these computer geeks who are
building a computer who needs personal
computers anyway it's only for big
companies but he didn't listen to them
he put the blinders on he was started
exploring his interests and this is a
toughest part you've got to believe that
somehow in the future the dots will
connect you know it doesn't make any
sense right now you've got to believe
that somewhere in the future it's all
going to come together by combining all
those different experiences and
different interests you have somewhere
in there is a huge multi-million dollar
business idea that will happen and
you're gonna love it but you got to
start you got to get up off the couch
get out start experiencing things start
working